على علب البلاستيك هذه يعتمد في اعاده
اسرته يغضو باطلا لجمع نحو 50 علبه من
شوارع المخاء ليعود مساءا بدولارين او اقل
لسد جوع اطفاله في مخيم النيابه وضعوا عبد
الله احمد كحالي عشرات النازحين الذين
هجرتهم من منازلهم في الحديده وتعز غربي
اليمن
[موسيقى]
على قدر الامكانيه حق المعيشه ههه
مشي حالي بالكيلوله دقيقه
هربنا من الحسين
ومن عذاب الحوتي ومن همم تصعيب المعيشه
ومن كل حاجه نعاني من كل حاجه وبحسب تقرير
الامم فان اكثر من مليون شخص نزحوا من
محافظه الحديده بسبب الانتهاكات الحوثيه
وارتفعت موجه النزوح خلال نوفمبر الماضي
الى اكثر من 70%
لتكتظو مخيمات النزول في المناطق المحرره
بالحديده والمخاه باكثر من 800 عائله قصص
ماساويه تعيشها الاسر الذي داخل هذه
المخيمات بعد ان هجرتهم الميلشات الحوثيه
من منازلهم في خطوط التماسي الحرب معاناه
تختزلوا بؤس الحياه في ظل الحرب الحوثيه
قال سعيد العربيه من مخيم العليلي
الجنوبيه الحديده